okay coming to you in five
four three two
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
tuesday edition
otherwise known as
holy enlightened correct opinion
zone if you plan on disagreeing with me
or
arguing with me that is not an option
don't close it because i do want you all
watching the numbers are important
but just know be forewarned you are
wrong
because this is the correct opinion zone
today's episode is sponsored by 23andme
quip and seek geek guess what's going
down a week from today
bill burr the living legend the titan of
comedy one of the greatest
comedians of all time he's gonna sit
right where ela is right now
that's good i'm [ __ ] terrified bill
burr is going to be here on tuesday also
important to note is that today is young
shredder's birthday he turned one years
old so
let's keep the round of applause going
glad
um we are going to be playing
everybody's favorite game know your meme
featuring the one and only
shoe nice that's right shoe nice is back
in a big way call us in at 808
hot meme that yes that is our real phone
number and yes we are taking calls there
808 hot meme ooh speaking of hot
i've been having diarrhea a lot of
diarrhea
labor day so hot well no the the poop is
hot like
parts yeah got it yeah why is diarrhea
hot by the way like
never had a chance to like cool you know
when you bake bread you're supposed to
let it cool
and like go room temp so that's what
diarrhea
is it's poop that never got to they
never got to go room temp
but that's why it's hot undercooked that
is the scientific
experience is what diarrhea is
i uh man happy labor day i hope you guys
all had a nice break
i had one too many hot dogs or something
because i've been having diarrhea since
4am
been really pooping my brains out what's
the deal with labor day by the way
the that freaking mailman's walking
around delivering mail yesterday
i'm like on labor day on labor day
federal
employees don't even get the damn day
off labor day what the hell
what are we celebrating if the mailman
can't go
you know take a seat that's weird i find
that really
very bizarre he just like decided to
work on his own
i don't think it works that way in the
federal government
i don't think you just pick up your mail
bag and just start passing out
you sure was a usps guy usps
because there's those amazon guys you
know what i'm not sure i didn't see him
there's probably an emergency
oh isaac well either way it's like you
know
late labor day the everyone who gets
labor day off for like white-collar
workers you know
the real people that need labor day off
are the ones that are like slaving away
at amazon and mcdonald's and all these
shitty jobs right
it's just so funny labor day has turned
into such a
stupid thing labor day was originally
made to celebrate unions and celebrate
like worker rights and [ __ ] and like
meanwhile you got the postman
and around envelopes but that's enough
about labor day
the real takeaway is that diarrhea is
under cooked poop that makes sense
um guys let's get started we got a lot
to talk about meme royale
is coming to fruition ksi versus logan
paul
everyone's saying oh that's the fight of
this year fight of the century not even
the fight of the year because we are in
the early stages
of organizing what is going to be known
forever as meme royale 2018 because this
my friends
is an annual event
we've got people that are in so far joey
salads
prank invasion shoe nice they're
bradberry
soflo all squaring off
hundred thousand dollars of prizes i
think the big
the big fight should be prank invasion
vs joey sauds
and then i think a great undercard would
be shoe nice for verse ethan bradberry
which would be the battle of madness
because they're both a little crazy
and i know shoe nice is like over the
hill so to speak
but he terrifies me and by the way he's
been working on he looks really good are
people going to place bats like sure why
not it's lost
i mean i'm not going to take bets but
somebody will
you know that's crazy i'm sure there'll
be a spread if we so guys
get excited memeroy l 2018 is
happening i want to see kobe person
getting
his hands dirty his face is too pretty
he would never jeopardize that
god kobe person who would you i would
like to see kobe versus like mo
because you know i was originally
that's a good match up i originally
wanted to pit ethan bradberry versus moe
bradberry like the
the boys yeah but i think i think ethan
would smash him
you can't contend with this the pure
madness that is behind his eyes
like you even see in their videos when
ethan's like
intimidating mo that's like damn he
would never have a chance so we'd have
to pit mo against
someone like dennis yeah that would be
pretty hot
super excited about that in fact guys uh
you may have been following the story as
it's been evolving here on this h3
podcast uh correct opinion
episode we've been having a little bit
of a altercation with prank invasion
who called me out to box me which was
the
you know i want to say how would you say
the
the breaking point for this meme royale
because prank invasion challenged me to
a battle and of course
that's not something that i'm interested
in doing seeing as that
i'm a pudgy little guy and prank
invasion
literally just got out of prison for
three years for some kind of sexual
crime
um that is not well it's literally well
i don't know what he i mean
no it's a it is a joke yeah that is it
is a joke what i'm saying
do i need to say that every time
maybe once guys i do not think i'm not
saying
that it's i wouldn't be surprised can i
say that if you went to prison for a
sexual crime
you can say that that's not that's not
definitely i wouldn't be surprised if
you're
i won't be surprised at all i'm
anticipating it um
so he he edited this footage together of
what i said last
episode and he said respect to h3h3
productions
for admitting he's scared takes a real
man to admit that
respect bro now send me your address to
the podcast and i'll actually play you a
quick game for a quick kiss
dude this guy wants to come
to our podcast i mean it's always so
demanding in his twitch
now quit playing i mean here's the thing
dude send me your address well i don't
know how he i don't know how he
yeah i'm scared of you i am scared of
you that's not like
that's not like unmanly to admit that
i'm scared of some unhinged psychopath
who's roided up and just got out of
prison for a sexual crime
like if you if you walked by some
unhinged lunatic with like a
hell's fire between his eyes under his
behind his eye
it's not crazy to be like yeah i'm
scared
scared of you dude um and not i mean and
and
it's because you're insane
you know let's get it straight then
you're not a man
you're not a man also like i'm not okay
well anyway let's just watch
his little edit here bro you look like
you disappeared for a year
and you were in prison and you've been
lifting weights that whole time
like the last video you made i was
scared i was scared i was scared i was
scared i was scared
this guy was in prison for a year bro
you literally
repeated me saying i was scared that you
were in prison for your first sexual
crime and we're lifting weights that
whole time
i am scared that you want to come to the
podcast and kiss me
i'm terrified of all these things and i
openly admit it if that makes me less of
a man
god bless okay
i wouldn't be surprised that all of that
guy went to prison for a sexual crime
within the next couple months
that's not defamation right i just want
people to know that this is a joke
because i could see some people start i
could see some rumors
starting to pile up that actually went
through the prison chris went to prison
for a sexual crime yeah
chris went to prison for a sexual crime
it's a joke he didn't but i wouldn't be
surprised that's all i'm saying
do you think i'm insane do you think
that's my skill that i would get in a
ring with you and fight you
i mean he his veins were like surging
like what did you do to be in prison for
the past two years to be there
he sees that as a compliment he's like
he thinks i'm so jacked he thinks i was
in prison for two years
well at any rate chris i would
definitely like to play you for a quick
game for a quick
kiss and i think that could be a special
segment at
meme royale 2018
quick game for a quick kiss bonus
edition
are you gonna play a rock paper scissors
can you imagine kissing chris his breath
is probably
so gross i bet you he has tonsil stones
i'm just worried about the noises more
than anything
a whole stain of people just listening
to him you think that i'm gonna make
that noise with them hilah
not you we should bring you know what
would be funny you know how you have
these ringside models at boxing matches
if we brought one of these girls to do a
quick game for a quick kiss with them
into the mic that'd be [ __ ] epic
either
seriously i'm down anyway
so yes i am scared of you good job
prank invasion you freaking sk you scare
the hell out of me
now interestingly joey salads is on the
phone
who was gonna who joey has challenged
prank invasion to a fight
i think it's gonna be a really good
fight
did brink frank invasion acknowledge
joey's
yes challenge it took some time it took
some finagling but we have actually
lined them up and i think this is
something that is going to happen
at first it was really hard to tell i i
had answered in response to this
fight joey sells my money's on salad all
day and the thought of you getting mommy
make out
date by a salad head keeps you up at
night
and then he said you want to put a
hundred thousand on it i said abso
[ __ ] lulu put 100 000 on it
goes to the winner winner takes all
those guys are gonna be out
for blood it's meme royale 2018.
where were you when the salads fell
now is this gonna be a real fighting
like or like fake fighting
what was this wwf yeah i don't know
pranks fake
fighting this i mean a hundred thousand
dollars is on the line to the winner
i'm not saying one is better than the
other like i mean
i'm not faking you want to fake it
i just can't believe like people will
actually hurt each other
well it's like logan ksi i mean they're
wearing gloves
yeah well this is this is when again
joey salad sent me this dm and i cleared
it with everybody to get the permission
to show this
so joey was trying to talk prank
invasion into having this fight and
again this is why
prank invasion scares the hell out of me
because this guy is so unhinged
that i wouldn't be surprised if he went
to prison for a sexual crime within the
next couple of months
joey said have you been training when i
had a box so anyway he says are you
going to do it prank invasion says
i'm thinking not boxing but mma
no gloves caged bear knuckle
fight we sign waivers and the fight
lasts until someone gets knocked out
unconscious
gives up or dies we'll need lawyers
like this guy is
i mean i can't tell if he's serious but
that sounds like the worst of us
absolutely joey said dude that's just
stupid
let's at least wear gloves i like how
joey's actually entertaining
is this not entertaining do you not
watch the h3 podcast live correct
opinion zone
for content just as this i asked who is
entertained right now
joey salads and pregnant bare knuckle
fight to the death
joey salads first prank invasion cage
fight
to the death we need lawyers and waivers
whoever thought we would get to this
point without all being said we've
talked enough about it let's see what
the salad man has to say about this
joey salad you are on the air and are
you scared like i am of prank invasion
i am i'm scared for his life really
because he's gonna have to sign a waiver
before the fight in case i accidentally
kill him
you think that you've got what it takes
to take out roid it out prank invasion
yeah i mean he's a little crazy a little
more than a little crazy but
now joey have you seen his physique in
his new videos he's clearly disappeared
and he's been lifting weights and he's
been getting a little crazy have you
seen this
i have seen it it's not right now it's
just it's
it's newbie games i mean he just started
working out
newbie games and um joey you had
mentioned to me
uh something about him wanting to fly
out and
fight you is this something that you
guys are going to be doing
off camera well and separate i don't
think so
it just sounds stupid he wants to
fight to the death i told him at least
let's do the boxing match first
and then fight today why does it want
someone to die
now what do you think now what's your
take on prank invasion joey do you
think he's being serious what has
happened because he's went from kissing
cuties on the boardwalk
to literally wanting to have a death
match what has happened in the world of
prank invasion joey can you tell us
you know what i i can't tell that i was
friends with him for like a week
like two years ago his friend's room for
a week and he seemed kind of normal
but then he was telling me uh that he uh
he suffered from low testosterone so he
needed to take testosterone
enhancement but i think he just started
taking those
and that might be making him lose his
damn mind because i know some people
they lose their minds when they start
taking like performance enhancing stuff
so so you're exactly dealing with so
it's possible that he turned up this
testosterone to
levels that are unstable
yes that's what i believe that is
fascinating now are you gonna be able to
contend with that massive overload of
male testosterone joey are you gonna
have to counteract
with your own testosterone or steroids
i've
i've got i've got my own testosterone
that
should be sufficient and um you had told
me an anecdote about how he has a secret
technique
that he did he beat up a bunch of dudes
on camera recently
but he didn't want to show you the video
do you have more information on that and
if you could stop washing dishes for a
moment that would be good for the show
you kept me on the line for 30 minutes i
started cooking so now i got to clean my
deal
can you hold off cooking the meal i mean
jesus come on man this is our moment
here we
we've we've prepared for this what are
you cooking joey what are you preparing
hopefully
i got a hard i got it's my protein meals
i'm already training i got like i'm
training in like an hour right now
are you doing meal prepping
yeah i got hard-boiled eggs i got uh
turkey patties all right as much as i'd
love to hear more i did ask but that's
enough of that
i've heard enough for your meal time
prep now tell me about this video that
prank invasion he says there's a secret
video of him
beating up several people by himself
now joey tell me about this video i
would give him a thousand dollars cash
if you would send it to me
because i don't think it exists because
you had asked him send me the video he
said i don't want you to see my secret
technique he said that verbatim
which made me think that it's kind of a
kissing prank thing of like
my secret technique yeah that's what it
kind of sounded like i think maybe what
he did was
he he uh tried to get into a fight with
someone and tried kissing them and then
they just ran away
very interesting theory that's the
technique
is there any other closing words any
words that you have for prank invasion
anything you would like to say
would you like to cast the gauntlet any
accusations any slander
about him being a sex uh criminal that's
been in prison for the last couple years
what would you like to add before we say
goodbye and let you cook your meal there
that you're so eager to cook
all i gotta say is if he bails out
i'm gonna be pissed and you're gonna be
a [ __ ] because he's been kind of flaky
with this whole thing
trying to go from boxing to cage death
match fighting
he's a flaky guy yeah i don't i can't
tell if he's trolling or if he's
actually
that weird well there's a hundred
thousand dollars on the line and i gotta
say
chris uh you know your channel has not
been holding up strong lately lots of
demonic citations
um and i think that a hundred thousand
dollars is a lot of money for
any man no matter how many girls he's
kissed am i right joey
it is okay well i'm excited everyone is
on the edge of their seat this is what
it's all about here at the h3 podcast
joey we love you we love having you be
part of the show
you're don't forget to eat those salads
i know that you're not a fan of salads
but it's important to fiber up
joey how do you get fiber when you're
preparing for to be to be in healthy
shape
seeing that you don't eat salads at all
well how do you get your fiber joey
fiber i got some fiber in my in the
bread that i eat the toast
that's it joey i'm a fr okay yeah
i'm not sure but i'm not sure i'm not
sure that's sufficient
not one to talk but i'm also not
training for the century
um how many hours a day are you trying
to joey
three four three four hours a day wow
that's impressive that's very good that
is a lot yeah now are you afraid that
prank invasion being a little bit of a
mad
dude is might be go for a ear bite or
something of that sort
that's what i'm worried about i'm gonna
tape my ears down to avoid that
keep the ears down i like that that's a
good idea better safe than sorry right
well yeah with a hundred thousand
dollars you can buy yourself a new ear
[Laughter]
joey we thank you we wish you all the
best
keep training keep eating that bread the
fiber is important i recommend metamucil
which is a great
fiber supplement that was recommended to
be my friend it's helped me out a lot
and i wish you all the very best joey
thanks for giving us a ring
thanks man thank you all right joey god
bless you keep keep uh
keep fighting all right you're the best
well there you have it
joey sal is in the flesh
now just to summarize joey he thinks
he's gonna win
i think joey's going to win he has
accused prank of agent of taking
testosterone which has made him kind of
i want to say rage-filled mania
has resulted in and he is he has called
out prank invasion and said
if you flake you're a [ __ ] he said
and i believe uh something else because
we know that he's flaky because we tried
to do the know your meme
and he was like i'm gonna do it and then
he never responded
well i think what we need to do next is
basically draft a contract between these
two
that locks them in and obligates and
basically if he
if bank invasion backs out of the
contract
what's going to happen is that i'm going
to be talk in contact with his probation
officer
and we're going to make sure that those
sexual crimes he has committed
are not going to be expunged and are
going to remain on the sex vendor
website
for a long long time just a joke
but we we should get a contract with the
with the guys
yeah but the thing is even without prank
invasion we still have a great fight
because shoe nice is going to tear
someone's head
off their body um
how we doing on time i guess we got a
little more time here
we actually here's some great footage up
next i got a lot to talk about before we
throw it to a commercial let's watch ted
cruz slam dunk
now ted cruz i don't know what the
situation here is but he's in a church
of all places playing hoop
and man oh man
can he throw a rock and by throw a rock
i mean drops like a rock but here let's
have a look
no sound so here he is prepping he's
about to take a run
that's travel he's not dribbling and he
tries to dunk it off a trampoline and
boy does he just fall like a stone
i mean like a bag of dirt
[Laughter]
shall we see that again yeah now you
hear you have ted cruz taking a running
jump at a trampoline to try to dunk the
ball at a church
down the the center lane i don't know
you call that a church
the pupils the pulpals how do you what
do you call those seats
pews the pews full
i think they're just in prayer praying
for ted cruz to hit a slam dunk
but the prayers were not answered and
he's straight to hell
it looks like the devil literally sucked
him down he like defies gravity
he drops faster and harder than gravity
allowed
i love it so anyway shout out to ted
cruz who
you know by all accounts
is hated by all but nobody could ever
say he's a bad
basketball player
next up here on the h3 podcast
we've got theresa may the british pm
dancing
and my dudes thank you for the social
bars
i mean get with it folks imagine going
to africa
like and doing this
[Music]
what the freaking heck is that
that's the whitest [ __ ] i have ever seen
in my life see i'm conflicted on one
hand
i don't know if i should be like hey you
know what you're making an
effort to yeah i love you
so like that's admirable right it is fun
i think it is
i mean that is that's like you know what
it reminds me of that episode of
seinfeld
yeah dancing it's that weird
it's weirder i think she's with her
hands she's like crying at the hair
it's like her body is broken she's like
clawing at the air and
man it's like it's bad
but i guess yeah i mean it's admirable
that she's out there
i don't know anything about her but it
makes me think
makes me like her she seems very likable
kind of a george
bush kind of thing where it's like you
know as a person
i don't i don't think about her either
but here's more of her dancing
[Music]
and she's getting in there
thrusting those hips and she looks like
she's hurting
sheep or something she's like look there
you go
what is it when you watch someone dance
that you have to like try to dance
remind me if i'm ever in this situation
just to smile and nod
it's kind of a lose-lose you can't yeah
i mean if you're just standing there
you're like one of those
people yeah i you know what god bless
her
right you crushed it man
that one's not nearly as good as the
first one with the clawing at the air
the clawing move was something i've
never seen before
that was a fresh move um anyway
off to a good start are we entertaining
here or what
boy so i guess that's been about 30
minutes hasn't it
so we'll throw it to a quick commercial
break we got back logan paul vs ksi
copyrighted our highlight i'm gonna rant
about that
[ __ ] we got pewdiepie versus
t-series t-series about to pass
pewdiepie and sub count
who the hell is t-series and how do they
have so many views and subscribers we're
gonna dig into that
and so so so much more new pitbull video
with a dancing frog
you're not gonna believe this is real it
is guys you're watching the h3 podcast
correct opinion zone
do not go away because my dudes that
would be wrong
and here we are right all the time stay
tuned
thank you to 23 and me for sponsoring
this episode
23 and me is a dna testing service that
can offer insights into your ancestry
health wellness and
traits 23andme health plus ancestry
services
includes reports on how your dna can
influence your weight sleep quality
caffeine intake sense of taste
and whether you are likely to be lactose
intolerant
now in my case i did do 23 million i
learned a lot about myself
sadly it doesn't help fix the things
that you found wrong with yourself but
it is interesting in the case of lactose
intolerance
i find that out every morning when i
look at the toilet that yes i
am lactose intolerant but it is good to
have the science to back it up
now it's easy to do you simply spit in a
tube which is the sexiest thing you
pretty pretty much do on the planet
provided to you in your 23andme kit mail
it
in you mail your saliva which is a
unique experience you're not going to do
anywhere else
and the sample get they the lab gets in
they analyze it now
they there's a guy in the lab he just
throws it in his mouth and flushes it
around
no i'm kidding they've got uh advanced
machinery that crunches the numbers
there now here's some things that you
might find out that might intrigue you
about yourself
bitter taste versus sweet and salty your
dna plays a role if
which foods you like and they're going
to tell you which one you are sleep
report are you a deep sleeper
or you a light sleeper well they'll
they'll they'll read your dna they'll
tell you all about it
pretty interesting stuff oh that's why i
never sleep
i thought it was because i'm just
neurotic and uh nope
not my fault there you go feel better
already
saturated fast reverse weight report
tells you based on genetics how your
weight might affect it by saturated fats
in your diet ex there you go
don't feel bad anymore yeah i'm a fat
cow oh it's in my dna can't do anything
about it sorry
i'm sorry uh offered to that's true it
gave you
i'm telling you this is there's a lot of
interesting stuff in here that you're
going to learn about yourself
and the world around you okay here's
what you need to do
to get started and spit in a cup a tube
if you were
order your 23andme health plus ancestry
service kit at 23andme.com
h3 that's two three
and me dot com slash h3 i'm telling you
it's so fun it's so interesting treat
yourself
and see what's going on in those genes
because uh there's much more than
meets the eye the jeans because you look
in your jeans i don't know
what else is there to say about electric
toothbrush
okay it's the greatest toothbrush on the
planet earth and take it from a guy
who's obsessed
with oral hygiene it's got it all let me
recap for you and i've got something
else to add
the brussel soft enough to not harm your
gums
firm enough to give your teeth a squeaky
clean it's got it all it vibrates
do you hear that welcome to h3h3 asmr
that's right
it vibrates and it tells you when to
switch
sides it tells you when you're done
brushing it's a three minute timer and
make sure that
you because your mom doesn't live with
you anymore and you have to take care of
yourself
are done brushing your teeth here's the
part that blows me away there's always
something new on the back of it it's got
this hard
rubber stop you know what that's for
either clean your
the gun the tongue it's a tongue scraper
and it works
brilliantly it's got it all in this tiny
little tube you guys
i cannot stress it enough try it out
you're gonna love it it's incredible
guys here's the offer from quip
if you don't have it now what are you
waiting for i mean seriously
quip starts at just twenty five dollars
okay
if you try to get an electric toothbrush
of a similar
caliber you're going to be dropping 200
on some
coal gate more like watergate because
it's such a scam when you buy colgate am
i right ela
yeah that's how i feel quip starts at 25
bucks go to getquip.com h3 right now
and you'll get your first refill pack
free
with equip electric toothbrush the
refill pack you pop this
off and a new brush head lands right on
there god
damn it that's your first refill pack
free
at get quipped dot com slash h3 spell
g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash h3
try it out you're gonna love it and
everyone
around you is gonna love it even more
because your breath stinks
thank you to see geek okay if you're
looking to go to a live show
an event a sporting event whatever it is
that it's got tickets
they've got you covered now let me tell
you about sea cake okay
you get a view from the seat whoa
right off the bat superior to the other
ones
oh my god am i sitting in front of a
giant pole i can't see
anything no you see the sea you know
exactly what you get
they rate it on a scale of one to ten
green is good red is bad so you know
if you're getting a good deal or not
right out the gate
boom it's simple as that they know what
they're doing
okay now i've established that it's a
great platform for buying tickets
seed geek but here's where [ __ ] just
gets crazy
okay because they want you to come try
their app they have got this offer for
our listeners that's out of this world
use code h3h3 when you download their
app with the link in the description
and you get straight up 20
off your first order oh that's just them
handing you a 20 bill this is a deal
that you don't see coming around very
often they just want you to try it out
and they've got 20 bucks on it
just for you to come see i mean
they're just hosting the tickets they're
literally giving you 20 bucks off your
ticket price i mean that's insane
so click the me tab on the app and enter
code h3h3
for 20 off your first purchase you got
the link in the description to download
the app guys
it's as simple as that give them a shot
i think they're great and they're giving
you 20 bucks just to put their money
where their dang mouths are
so head on over to seek you i love them
i appreciate them
and god bless them as well and god bless
you
and the twenty dollars you're going to
be saving with c geek
welcome back from the break guys
uh today we've got a special
presentation put together of know your
meme featuring the
one and only shoe nice we've got a
caller on the line here
let's get started so
uh let's head on to jail joe
you're over there and welcome to
know your name joe how are you doing
today
let's do that i'm doing fantastic even
better now i'm talking to my favorite
couple on youtube
oh thank you joe you're too kind too
kind do you know shoe nice are you ready
to win
a samsung galaxy s9 plus
oh hell yeah let's do this all right
i've met this dude before
i you've met shoenice before tell me
about that interaction if you
yeah so uh it was 2011.
uh i was a freshman at uh state
university of new york at albany uh and
mr shoenice kind of hijacked
uh the cancellation of one of the
biggest student events
uh by chaining himself to a fountain in
the middle of our campus
uh he wore diapers to go to the bathroom
and he didn't eat for
oh it was probably at least four or five
days now can you
tell me why well
so the biggest uh party of the year at
that school is uh it was fountain day
when they would turn on the fountain in
the spring everybody would
go in and basically get a giant pool
party but for st patrick's day there's
another
uh unsanctioned event called kegs and
eggs
uh which is just basically everybody
wakes up at eight o'clock in the morning
and starts drinking
uh so long story short um a few police
cars were flipped over people were on
top of cars playing bagpipes
the real [ __ ] show um so they ended up
actually canceling the fountain day
event
and shoe nights uh who claimed to be a
student
uh chained himself to the fountain uh
and nobody really at that time kind of
knew who he was
i don't even know if he had the
following now i don't know if he has the
following now but
i am slightly confused is he protesting
the event or the cancellation of the
event
the cancellation of the event he uh he
claimed to be a student
which uh was a little bit interesting
so you said he exchanged himself and he
[ __ ] himself in a diaper and fasted
for four to five days did he achieve uh
success in his hunger strike
no i think he was actually forcibly
removed at some point but we did not
have valente that year
so uh he tried
did you have the opportunity to meet
this great man and talk with him and say
shoo
tell me about what you're doing and can
i smell your
you diaper nobody really knew that he
was the guy eating tampons on youtube
you know everybody thought he was like
the warrior
you know fighting for the students did
they know he was just getting up there
he was trained up there in his giants uh
gear just you know
screaming at anybody who walked by he
got all the local press to pay attention
to him
um that that's not originally visited
him once or twice
that story definitely lines up with the
shoe nice we all know and love
you know no problem stretching my
imagination to believe that
better than our words joe absolutely
we've got you here
we are ready to play let's just get
right the f
into it and start with the first
question so
up get ready
shotgun a bottle of alcohol
let's start with question one
what is the weirdest thing shoe nice has
eaten
is it a a bottle of k-y
jelly anal lube
anal not normal vaginal lube there is a
distinction i want you to be aware of
b tampons soaked in hot sauce
joe or see a bar of deodorant the choice
is
yours joe
oh [ __ ] the weirdest that's subjective
that is like he's eating all those
things
in his opinion this is in his opinion
well you your job is is not to seek
truth joe
i remind you it is to get into the mind
of the shoe
himself that what size is that shoe and
does your head fit into it that's this
we are running out of time you have 20
seconds joe
ah i thought the tampon was blood but
i'm gonna say the deodorant
c the weirdest thing shoe nice has ever
eaten c deodorant
this is really anticlimactic but i don't
have the folder open with the
answers just
uh go ahead and just everyone chill back
i would have to say the weirdest thing i
ever ate was probably a tube of
ky jelly know lubricant clothes first
with three tampons dipped in uh hot
sauce
now joe i have to say i'm somewhat
disappointed that a bar of deodorant and
set next to anal lube and a tampon
soaked in hot sauce that you found
the deodorant the least bizarre or the
most bizarre the three of those but
that just shows what a decent
kind-hearted uh man you
are now i remind you the objective is to
get into the
shoe itself so
going forward we got more questions
though we got to get into the shoe
joe you with us all right i got to get
more depraved
let's do it yeah you got to get into the
shoe so here we go question number two
that's fine we've got plenty more to go
what did shoe nice tell ela that
prompted her to tweet
this ela said to him slam
some more toilet paper to clean the [ __ ]
that's becoming
out of your mouth what provoked
this from ela ay
shunais told her her clothing line
sucks b he called her an israeli
[ __ ] or c he said he wanted to eat
our dog shredder joe enter the shoe
this one i know he he called you uh
israeli horror
and i'm so sorry that that's horrible
and you're sweet
your sweet sweet man joe we appreciate
the uh
the sympathy so let's go to the uh
answer books itself b called her an
israeli [ __ ]
got to be a little more slick and prompt
these up more on time here we go
[Music]
this is real [ __ ] yeah well what
happened is that was my drinking days
i've been sober since last christmas eve
but
um ethan and me had talked on an email
and i was heading out to california
and ethan's like it would be great for
us to get together and i
emailed ethan a few more times and it
came up
you know he wouldn't reply to me and i
was just like well can you let me know
within the day
and then i i was just on twitter and i'm
a ball buster so
i just you know i said hey ela you know
you're a jewish [ __ ]
and i mean no i'm sorry you're a [ __ ]
from israel that's what i said if she
was from tennessee
she would have been a [ __ ] from
tennessee but yeah i'm not i'm not rea i
i wanted to take that back so bad i mean
i was literally i don't even remember
typing it to be honest
with you well joe you are correct in
this point but i actually
i want to correct the record with shoe
nice
what happened i think was that he wanted
to come on the podcast he had emailed me
and it was like so tentative he was like
hey i'm coming through la
uh maybe i'll pop in and we can do a
podcast or something and i was like
i was like sure i'll let you know mm-hmm
something like that
then he think about it or something like
that yeah and then he emailed me like 20
times and weirded me out and i was like
oh
[ __ ] shoe nice is crazy
i i didn't get money dude i hadn't yet
learned to harness that power
it scared me but i didn't i needed to
learn to harness
the power of a star as thor's hammer
does
um so then he just went railing on us
one night on twitter
that being said joe you were correct yep
you are on the board
one to one we're all very excited for
you how you feeling you feeling good
feeling confident that's right oh hell
yeah
let's do it samsung galaxy s9 plus with
a retail value of
one thousand dollars terrific phone i
use it myself
pretty excited for you joe so here we go
let's do it on to
question number three now this one
is a tuffy
[Music]
how many youtube accounts does shoe
nice have
now you may have seen in our previous
episode of the tuesday
edition that shoe nice left so many
comments
on our video it was heights of
insanity i've not known on youtube until
now
so i ask you this joe is it a
nine youtube accounts is it
b 29 youtube accounts
or is it c joseph
50 youtube accounts enter the mind of
shu
and tell me what is your answer
go big or go home c wow
well joe you are entering the mine of
shoe and i like to see that
you've wha you've dropped all rationale
all reason
you have put your head in the shoe and
joe
i love it let's hear the answer
that is a lot to coordinate all right
i don't remember this being this card i
have 50 youtube accounts i think that's
for the limit
but they have all history they have
subscribers videos on them they're
really not ghost accounts they all have
history and
interaction i use them exactly how i got
um top comment on ethan's video i'll
post a comment and then
switch to another account and it'll just
list them so all i'm doing
is just hitting switch account another
channel bouncing in
liking commenting but it sounds crazy
but
yeah that's all me bro it does sound
50 youtube accounts that he switches wow
shoe nice i'm telling you this guy is a
legend i think he is going to be the
first
official member of the goof troop the
goof gang
the goof gang what do we like goof troop
or goof gang
goof gang is more of an alliteration joe
what do you think yeah
goof squad goof squad partial to gaff
pack
gaff pack i mean why can't it be all of
those names
well we got a brand you know we gotta
brand it appropriately you gotta leave
it up to the people
yeah yeah yeah oh damn let's do a poll
right now as we speak we have the power
we've got the twitter potential
so we've got goof gang we've got goof
troop
goof troop that's kind of i like goof
troop and then what
squad you what had you suggested uh uh
young joseph
i had said the goof squad but now i i'm
liking yours a little buttered
well let's add it but i shouldn't
pollute the pool let's add it for the
sake of
historical preservation perseverance
definitely
and i then had one did you have one you
wanted to add anyone else
i said gaff pack yeah i'll throw it up
there
but what but throw that poll up there
dan and keep us updated copy that
um that's on our twitter by the way at
h3 podcast if you guys want to
participate
but i have a feeling that shoe nice
himself is going to be like
a true like founding met
member of this organization because he's
special
he's your beetlejuice he is he's my
beetlejuice i genuinely think so like
like i i i i love him i think he's got
so much potential you know sunis doesn't
even understand
how surreal this whole experience is
because we used to watch his videos like
dude i've been long ago deodorant bars
all my life
um actually i had some videos i wanted
to watch you wanna watch some videos joe
uh you're on the scoreboard you're two
to one maybe it would help you to
enter the mind of shu i want to show you
guys a video
um asmr marge this is actually from
his new v because he started so many
channels
he's such a weirdo he erases all the
footage on his old videos
all the time and then he makes a channel
called
shoe nice deleted videos so he erases it
on one channel
re-uploads it on another and it's just i
don't
he's just on another level so he's into
asmr i don't know what
sparked should do nice of all people to
get into asmr
but he has this character marge simpson
asmr and this
video was just from um oh it's from the
turn of the year it's at the end of
2017.
but here is a little glimpse of shoe
nice marge simpson
asmr and this is completely sincere this
is not
some kind of uh bizarre surreal humor
this is shunai's doing mark simpson asmr
hey everyone shoe nice asmr
he's whispering that's why it's so quiet
i didn't realize
how many people were affected
physically and emotionally
by my asmr
either way
[Laughter]
basically just he sounds the same you
just have to turn the volume up
that's what asmr is all we need is the
voice from
by the way i've been watching more asmr
counting 100
you'll be asleep either way
we have a special asmr guest here today
she would like to say the alphabet in a
few words
ladies and gentlemen marge simpson
[Music]
oh my god do you see that march just
walked in hi
everyone this is my first day
i just want to try the alphabet ready
[Music]
oh my god imagine waking up to this
sound
imagine the middle of the night oh the
idea is to fall asleep to this sound
not quite sure what's asmr about the uh
huh so this is what we're dealing with
here folks
all right you guys you guys have
seen enough so joe watch more tonight
joe yeah exactly joe will you be
watching that to help you sleep tonight
absolutely not all right i hear you uh
that's being said you
are on the scoreboard two to one joe we
applaud you we're excited for you we
think you're great we think you have all
the potential in the world
let's move it on to question four this
is basically
if you win this um
you get it all this is it
right not the last question not the last
question with you when's this he gets
the dang phone
so with that being said joe are you
ready to play
papa bless yesterday okay here we go
how many times or
has shoe nice ever
had alcohol poisoning
for those of you that don't know shoe
nice famously takes a whole bottle of
booze
puts it upside down no hands
and drinks it straight down the throat
and like a second
he's done it with handles okay
so has shoe nice ever had alcohol
poisoning
joe that is the question of him a
never not once
be one time
or c seven times
huh it's a tough one joe what do you
think
what do you what are you feeling
i wouldn't say never it's a good guess
i mean shoe nice is definitely the kind
of guy that would never
have ever had alcohol poisoning it's a
great guess but is it correct
well joe let's find out
[Music]
i passed out with the devil springs 160
proof
i wasn't dead i just go to bed but i
happen to have friends over at the time
and they couldn't wake me up so they
brought me to the hospital
i'm a veteran so my insurance is free i
didn't care but i woke up with a tube
down my throat here pumping my stomach
and i was just like whoa whoa whoa
you're gonna kill my buzz
well joe it turns out it was one time
and the doctors
killed his bud instead of killing him
apparently uh you you were wrong but
that is
fine joe because you're doing great
you're on the board it's two to two
this is exciting this is good for us i
like this excitement the cliffhanger is
terrific
but this one is i don't think you'll
have any problem if you're a shoe nice
fan so let's just pop right into the
fifth question
joe how does shoe nice show gratitude
a thank you
b thank you
or c thank you very much
did i differ differentiate those innova
do you get pretty good did you catch me
uh do you catch my drift on that joe do
you have a
do you did you understand the question
could you repeat the answers please
thank you
hey thank you
b thank you very much
see
thank you
now that's a yeah are you rehearsing are
you
answering
thank you very much just restating them
okay
all right joe i'm liking where your
head's at
and i'm feeling pretty good about this
show gratitude i usually say thank you
there you go you did it
you beat the gauntlet it was a close
call you know it was
three to two you pulled it out at the
very end though how are you feeling
oh fans [ __ ] fantastic just talking to
you guys is like a trip
i i love you guys so much well thank you
thank you
thank you thank you john evans
shout out to sean evans for showing so
many like
great people on hot ones and getting
like i found so much [ __ ] through him
found you guys
oh really there all your guests all your
all your guests are amazing
it's like i find then i found kill tony
it's unbelievable
like i love it they're going to be a
guest on our show soon
yeah but thank you i can't wait for that
we love you as well yeah
thank you thank you guys enthusiasm
stay on the line i'm going to get your
info so we can send this to you right so
joe it was a pleasure to talk to you i
wish you all the very best
and um thank you so much for listening
and enjoy this galaxy
plus thank you guys so much
all right talk to you thank you so that
was great
that was awesome um now there is one
bonus question left ela do you want to
play
yeah do you have the answer yeah
[Laughter]
well let's just play it let's just play
the
question is what's the first thing he
ate on youtube so here you guys go
my first stunt was a roll of toilet
paper single ply
double file clog up the system
yeah so we finally found someone that
likes single ply toilet paper
so that's why they make it just for shoe
nice tv
well guys that was another successful
edition of know your meme
congratulations to joanna's
samsung galaxy s9 plus yeah um
what else we got to talk about man i
mean that's i don't
i mean that's the best [ __ ] no we have a
lot more to talk about
um let's see what's next
logan paul these [ __ ] guys okay logan
paul versus ksi
the promoters whoever's involved in this
[ __ ] is such
dicks now we talked about this and we
made a highlight of it which was like 20
minutes long
and
i barely i didn't even show footage
because i knew that there were going to
be dicks about it
yeah we didn't even show the only thing
was one dude's compilation of jake
paul getting punched in the face yeah
but that was like which by the
way has intrinsic
artistic value
that that is the legal language i mean
let's be real
so for them to [ __ ] block it
worldwide
you stupid [ __ ] and here's the best
part
i dispute it and i'm like hey [ __ ] boys
hey idiots
you know release the claim
and they can keep it down for 30 days
youtube gives them 30 days to just sit
on that
and keep it down like the video should
go up
if i dispute it the video should go back
up
i mean that's just it's it's crazy
and they're such [ __ ] too by the way
ksi the video is just down for 30 days
yeah removed yeah and then at 30 days
they'll be like oh you're right sorry
it's back up but nobody wants to watch
it anymore yeah but like
you know ksi and logan paul ksi
specifically is a guy
that reacts to videos all the time on
his channel i mean
this is honestly just sad and i know
this has been happening to a lot of
people
it's just it's and you know you know
what really pisses me off about it is
like
before the fight they feed on
everybody's publicity
and everybody's talking about and before
the fight fair use oh great
yeah talk about it all you want after
the fight
talk for 22 minutes and don't even
[ __ ] show the footage and we're gonna
block it worldwide
i swear to god there's a case for like a
a class action lawsuit because
it's so abusive i mean they haven't
known
so exploitive they have no right to
remove it
it's just that's what i said i said i
said you have absolutely no right
yeah that's just how the tools work so
they can
well i think youtube needs to modify the
system so that when you dispute it
okay now the video's back up and now if
you want to
strike my video if you want to put your
money where your mouth is and make a
legal claim
then go right ahead
it's so frustrating man and for me it's
not it's not that big of a deal because
it's just
one highlight of a lot but like yeah i
mean it had 300 000 views in like
half a day but if that's your main
content and they can just
stomp on you like that it's just [ __ ]
up
i don't know man not happy about that
that really pissed me off
and they're intentionally just sit gonna
sit on it for 30 days
because they want people to go by the
pay-per-view that's so stupid
it doesn't really make sense no one is
going to watch our highlight instead of
that
there's no competition exactly if
anything it's going to make people want
to go watch
yeah that's the whole thing that i've
never understood about most
copyright copyright issues where it's
like almost
every time except for pure
re-upload yeah is going to result in
more
traction to your original product
it's just so pathetic so i want ksi and
logan paul
both to know and i'm sure both of them
will easily be like uh
oh that's just uh that's just our
production company
you know what they do first of all
[ __ ]
i'm i'm not letting you get a pass on
that look at this [ __ ]
they they make it under this like shell
the shell company ath piracy
there's no information there's no
accountability
it's just this it i mean this is ksi and
logan paul
and all these guys getting around having
to take responsibility
for doing something shitty that they
know is wrong on youtube
ath piracy give me a [ __ ] break
and the real crime is look at that
thumbnail so good the world deserves
that
i agree i love that thumbnail good dan
that was you dan by the way
your copyright dispute is currently
being reviewed by the copyright owner
you'll receive response within 30 days
how about three days how about they have
24 hours and then the video goes back up
and they can decide in 30 days
why are you on the deck of abusers
youtube
like it's time to do this differently
they have been improving though well i
think people have been less aggressive
like um we had this video on ethanol
where we reacted this lady
like dancing to hip hip-hop and it was
apparently attempted to be removed but
youtube said no
so they'll send you an email saying this
was
there was an attempt but we said no
actually i have to
give huge credit to that apartment that
used to never happen
that that's actually happened to us
several times where we got an email
being like
and the best part is they say who tried
to take it down yeah
it's for some reason when someone tries
to take it down and they reject it i see
their email their phone number their
name their channel
i get their social security number
basically
no and they're like this idiot at this
address
tried to remove your video and we gave
him the middle finger but somehow when
these [ __ ] do it
it's a total [ __ ] shot in the dark
you know it's not it's just i honestly
want to blame
these guys because they know what
they're doing and whoever put this
together know that
they're youtubers they know how it works
they're willfully abusing the systems
that youtube has put in place
that generally work pretty well most of
the time
and it's just it's so lame especially
ksi because he does reaction videos
he relies on other people's content you
know the paul brothers you can't expect
anything from them
ever now you guys know the law
better than most because of the lawsuit
that you went through and everything
um the whole 30-day thing is that
youtube policy or is that
the is that the actual legal law like
the dmca thing oh that's just youtube
yeah i'm i'm 99 sure that's just
unrelated
completely unrelated to the law weak i
mean youtube put their policies in place
originally basically they were faced
with
a huge decision when they were in their
infancy and people were pirating content
all the time and putting it on youtube
and so they had an existential crisis
where they needed to deal with this
issue or get sued into oblivion and not
be a legitimate platform
yeah and so they are very legitimate and
they do have a pretty good system like
if you compare it to facebook there is
no system at all
yeah so youtube is pretty good it's just
it's hard to deal with so many people
and yeah there's always going to be
someone who will abuse it
it is i mean this video in particular
it's just so
frustrating because i didn't even show
the footage yeah we're just talking
about i literally
explicitly avoided showing the footage
because i wanted to avoid this
and now 30 days and i'm
help i can do nothing it's just
so effed up it's so
whack dude it's seriously so whack so
you know [ __ ] these guys i don't know
hey speaking of whack got a 3 000
responses on this poll
already oh yeah give us the uh
information well i got to tell you we
are
deadlocked at 33 each between duke gang
and goof troop both 33 trailing a little
behind
is gaff pack at 27 and then poor goof
squad nobody nobody's on board with
google
so what are the what are the top two
again can you uh uh google
and goof troop they are gang goof troop
i think
i personally think the goof game because
yeah i was just gonna say
that i would vote for that one goof gank
let me vote right now
he was going to tip the scale all right
that's interesting to know
um anyway
pewdiepie here's another one this one
pewdiepie as everyone knows has been
the biggest subscribe channel on youtube
for pretty much ever as far as i can
in common history and he's up to like 65
million subscribers now
but out of nowhere comes this channel
t-series
they're at like 60 million subscribers
and their channel
is going insane and i'm thinking who
who are these guys yeah what is t-series
and so that is what i'm here
to answer for all you guys today what is
t-series
first let's start by looking at their
stats okay let's pull up the social
blades here
for t-series now past 30 days
2.1 and a half billion
views yeah i saw that number and like
i was like wait there's too many numbers
too many digits uh in the past 30 days
they've had 4.3
million subscribers eight plus plus the
grade
4.3 million in the last 30 days yeah
their parents would be probably i mean
compare that with pewdiepie
let's see damn like pewdiepie has
150 million views so which is a lot
he's about uh i mean they have what did
what did they have
like three billion yeah and not another
comma
and he's under a million so they're on
on subs per month which of course is
nothing to scoff at
but they are on track quickly to pass
young felix here it's so funny that
there's a grade
there's a double plus a plus plus oh
yeah
they're breaking the metrics here so 2.1
billion views that is just
madness so okay who the hell are they
and why are they getting so many
freaking
subscribers and views t-series
well the answer should
not surprise you i don't know what these
big channels are always so weird
it's just it's like bollywood [ __ ]
it's just a bunch of bollywood [ __ ] and
you know
i was looking at the population of india
these [ __ ] have like 1.4
billion people in india
they're about to pass china as the most
populous country so
they are churning out youtube views and
unprecedented numbers
if i was indian i'd be crushing it
getting 10 million views a day
um so anyway i curated some of their
videos to show you guys what's going on
with t
series here let me show you first show
the channel yeah let's let's look at the
channel
now they upload a ungodly amount
here ten hours six hundred thousand
views nine hours
twenty thousand so the variance is quite
large
you know one day a hundred thousand
views and then you go down a little bit
and you can see so
the views are pretty paltry but then
here you see five days ago
20 million views
excuse me i'm allergic to views
and so then you keep going through here
and you see these little nuggets like oh
six days ago 11 million views
you know one week ago 10 million views
so
these guys are just [ __ ] out so much
bollywood that it's giving my wood
bali i'm getting a bali hard on right
now looking at these numbers
right how is it possible the channel
like
like because if it's the if the views
vary so much why do people subscribe you
know
usually those kind of channels will not
have subscribers because they just kind
of like
the truth is and you're right sometimes
it will be a viral video but mostly not
you know
the truth is that is correct because if
you look at the ratio
they have over 2 billion
views a month and they're getting 3
million
subscribers i think pewdiepie's view to
subscriber ratio is way higher
but he's getting like 20 or 30 less
views per month
you know but there's the scope of views
is insane it's like everybody in india's
got the hard lined in t series
man so let's watch some of their
greatest hits we've
curated india's finest bollywood here
for you guys
and um let's see what these guys are up
to shall we
now what do we got here
this is their most popular video yeah
whoa look at the views almost 600
million views
just it's only a couple months old or
well several months old
let's have a look is it like their vego
what is that is it they're what like
vivo yeah i guess it's like indian vivo
that's right
now this this bollywood is the corniest
[ __ ]
on the on the history of the earth i
don't think anything has ever been
produced corner than bollywood
here's a guy uh he's texting
while driving and he almost plows down
cuts short the lives of two sweet
innocent young girls
do they react poorly and say hey i'm
calling the police [ __ ] you
no a seduction happens from this
of course
look at him he's on his phone it's not
like he almost murders
and cold manslaughter
he's like hey what's up girl i almost
[ __ ] killed you huh
so anyway yadda yadda
guys by the way too are like the
corniest mother dude
here
[Music]
anyway they all [ __ ] at the end of the
day you know how it goes
um thought that was interesting no i i
listen what you got another video
i i i'm not trying to slam bollywood
obviously i'm making i'm goofing around
you know let me step back a minute it's
just
the indian sense of culture and
entertainment and masculinity and
femininity and all these things
are so different it's just an
interesting thing to behold
and aren't all indians the goofiest
people you've ever met in your life no
i'm kidding that was a joke
i was stepping back and then plowing
forward ela thought about it she's like
i was gonna say no i was gonna say they
are actually very nice
the ones that i knew goofy though
maybe i'm kidding about it i don't
actually think that come on
this is the h3 podcast opinion zone all
right you entered
everyone enters not everyone leaves uh
what else we got here
i guess that's about it you get the idea
here's another one
this one has 210 million views in less
than one
month there you go they just they have
so many you're see what's the criticism
of me right now
i don't know you're such a bigot
this is such a big there's no criticism
there's one opinion here
and it's correct you're such a bigot
ethan
so close-minded ethan is so
disrespectful other people's cultures
yeah well give me one of these give me
one of these and [ __ ]
you know go subscribe to t-series
if you're so multicultural why don't you
go subscribe to t-series with
notifications on
probably already did anyway i thought it
was interesting
if you guys are clued to the tv about
this rivalry
there is of course a live counter of
pewdiepie versus
two series live stream live updates with
music and everything you need to be
entertained let's
take a look at the numbers well we've
got pewdiepie on the rise
t-series is catching up quick oh i gave
them like a date
yeah they're gonna creep up really fast
so that's out there if you really have
nothing better to do
what else
pitbull came out with a new video that
is truly
something i couldn't believe is real
this is why i showed up to work today
yeah we've talked about pitbull here on
the podcast with jack and eric
and man this new one i couldn't believe
i can't believe what i'm seeing
is this frog like i see the frog here so
i guess it's a reoccurring meme you see
this healer this has 800 million views
oh the one i got missing something let
me watch this this is 800 million views
it's just a dancing frog that looks so
weird what the [ __ ] look at it
it has 800 million views that's almost a
billion views oh so that is not related
to pitball
guys this is 800 million views this is
the channel here
um el champo ultra music
could you do this possibly to this music
are the latins on this
i don't think so they're more salsa it's
like a mix with like they're more of
this it's more
yeah yeah dan smith this frog is on a
he's on mars because i ain't never
damn this [ __ ] is so weird that 800
million people watch this
who made this and why it's good [ __ ]
this quality content
what are you talking about bro why is
the whole world so weird like
okay latin america now is on my goofy
list
i wonder what is it in america that
white people do that everyone else is
like those [ __ ] are weird
apparently [ __ ] without a bidet based
off the responses we've gotten
really yeah i mean all the emails that
i've been seeing and
people wipe their [ __ ] with their
hand i think that's probably not
totally different ian
look there's someone look that up
because i don't want to be that ignorant
to get that wrong
well maybe some i mean there's 1.3
billion people in india you know yeah
um well what is it about yeah
i know there's something that we're all
fat probably they're like whoa you're
all fat and that's
and you don't talk about that all the
time it's
yeah that's pretty that's a big one
that's kind of big morbidly obese is
pretty wild
i think it's just like being overly
polite
maybe but is that the same thing as 800
million people watching a dancing frog
i'm not sure that's on the level but
here's this video
i don't think so hilo who would you
rather [ __ ] pitbull or the frog
i gotta go with the frog really
i wonder how pitbull feels about that
although you're not alone all those
girls seem to want to [ __ ] frog
i'm being frank with you he's got crazy
hip thrust that frog he can really shake
it
he looks like salad fingers i mean it's
just not human
it's just not right you know
close your eyes and and don't say a word
all right i've seen enough of that frog
whoa i really wonder what white people
do
that words the rest of the world out
um what else we got
this one god i feel like i'm being so
ignorant this episode but i gotta plow
on
doesn't get better from here guys i'm
reading the meaning of dharma to casey
what does it mean maybe you should read
this
where where is it located where are you
reading it it is located on the google
i don't help me out i am
dama tu cosita means um
right cosita it means and it's got a
picture of the frog then so i know i'm
right
it means um stay still
and be quiet and this will all be over
soon
no it kind of means give me your little
thing
whoa that's even weirder than what i
said so the little translation of the
word cocita is innocent enough
it means little thing the course of this
ditty is dripping with sexual innuendo
in latin america dame tu cosita means
give me your reproductive part
whoa this frog is crazy
dame tu cosita
holy [ __ ]
give me your little part i'm sure it
doesn't really translate
that's what they're saying they're
saying in latin america that means give
me a reproductive point i think with
like the implications no i think it's
like
give it give it give it to me babe yeah
yeah
i think that frog has got more planned
than you know dan
okay let's move it on you guys know
about this tess
holiday she's a plus model i want to
handle this story as tactfully and
artfully
as i can't because i feel like i have
something a legitimate
thing that i want to express about this
okay i don't know what that was
and i don't want to be you know i want
to handle this
uh you know politically here okay now
we've got tess holliday
and she's featured on the cover of
cosmopolitan she's a plus-size model
plainly you can see that
it's extremely plain to see
and um and so
this whole thing about like you know
they're trying to normalize and say like
hey you don't have to be
in shape or supermodel right
to be on the cover of cosmopolitan or to
be an
object of beauty and admiration right
it's like a healthy at every size kind
of thing yeah and
and when i saw this i was like you know
if you're going to criticize
magazines for putting anorexic girls on
the cover
which promotes an unhealthy lifestyle
i don't see that this is any different
when you put a morbidly obese person on
a magazine and glorify it
that's just as unhealthy as anorexia
i mean i'm not i'm not saying she's not
beautiful or that someone would not be
attracted to her
but like i don't understand this
argument of saying
somebody is fit and attractive
and works super hard on their health and
their fitness
by the way i have so much respect
for people that actually maintain their
physical body because
rich or poor or whoever you are
you have to put in the work there's no
shortcuts
there's no work around whoever you are
from
the king to the peasant if you want that
body it takes raw
work and dedication now
this does not require that there's no
there's nothing in my mind commendable
there's nothing in my
and i'm not and i'm not saying [ __ ] her
because she's fat that's not my point
is but that we look at someone who is
physically fit
that they have achieved something and
that's why we admire them and we put
them on
magazines because everybody has it the
potential within them
to carve their body out of marble
so to speak you know to chisel away
through hard work
that perfect body but this
there's no there's nothing admirable
i mean there's there's no uh achievement
there's no hard work and sacrifice just
it's just the conversation it took a
weird turn like instead of saying
you don't you can feel uh
confident you know you can you don't
have to feel horrible about yourself
yeah and be plus-sized but
you don't need to glorify it either i
find it bizarre i find it
frankly bizarre to glorify
i mean a more a morbid illness
i mean we sat here and talked with
boogie who was more
the guy is not there's nothing good
about
being morbidly obese and if you feel
good and happy with yourself
god bless but like these are the same
people that are saying oh these anorexic
models are not realistic yeah they're
not realistic
they're models it takes a lot of hard
work to
look that good physically
to get a six-pack and have a [ __ ]
crazy
ass and thighs and be like fit beautiful
person right
yeah it's not realistic it's really hard
to do that so
um i think this is weird
i think it's weird i don't get it and by
the way also i just want to point out
too
people always talk about like photoshop
and like oh that's not realistic it's
photoshopped
she is photoshopped
all the way those thighs and her
chest and her arms and everything her
face
is so photoshopped and i have to tell
you
my hunch is that that unedited video
that unedited photo you would look at it
and be like
that lady is sick
not disgusting but i mean like you see
what morbid obesity looks like
they've paint brushed it and brushed it
and made it look beautiful and
attractive and
hey she's got soft skin and she looks
good and she's got tattoos and [ __ ]
she has a little miss piggy on her
forearm incidentally
i didn't say that i mean it's right
there miss biggie's on her phone yeah
the the treatment to the photo
is the same as the ones they're
criticizing she's still got makeup she's
got
exactly paradigms there's photoshop you
can see exactly
the shading and everything is on it must
have been touched you know in photoshop
and by the way i've met a lot of
morbidly obese people
i'm a fat guy not obviously to that
level like buggy was saying like
i think morbidly obese people it's it is
like an illness
as i understand it but like there is
nothing happy
about that i don't know i don't know i
don't i just don't
i don't get it i think it's dangerous i
think we as a society
need to stop being like i guess i just
don't know what's the point
i mean like
we're over the point where we're like
you're
fat and shame on you and whatever but
like
to put someone up who's sick and say
like they're to glorify it in the same
way it just seems hypocritical
yeah this was a tough one to talk about
they're hailing her as brave i mean
what's brave about you know
eating ice cream
did i go too far i don't know
i don't know can i get one of these
was waiting for a joke yeah i said
nothing now
you know what does bother me though
is on the other hand let's get our [ __ ]
straight okay
like we've got this [ __ ] on but the re i
think the real damaging [ __ ] that's
going in magazines right now
is these kim kardashians okay with
fake asses performed through dangerous
procedures
see that is unobtainable
so then you've got these little these
poor girls who are working their ass off
to
try to obtain an ass like kim kardashian
which is
actually literally impossible now that
is an unrealistic
goal to set i mean here let me let me
show you these kim kardashian before and
after
these these these kardashians are
[ __ ] twisted dude
they've had so much surgery like there's
nothing
left of like who they used to be and it
is so
i feel like it's so damaging for
actually for for young women who
are comparing themselves look at this
this is gonna [ __ ] crack you up
look at this look at that ass before and
after
yeah looks like she just
looks like she's got like whoopee
cushions in her
i feel like even the picture on the
right is not updated anymore
it's gotten bigger progressively bigger
i don't know
her ass has gotten so freaking big look
at this one
i mean get the hell out of here with
this
which one do you want to see um
just there's like a dress there in the
middle
anyway all of them have these like
bodies that were created in laboratories
i mean if you want to talk about some of
these unhealthy that's what's up now
actually i have a story here about and
it's really sad
uh what are we going to say you is some
dad no
this lady went to
get a bum lift as they call it a mother
of three was told by her partner she did
not need surgery
but obsessed with these images of kim
kardashian all these women
with fake asses was one of the strangest
phenomenons i would say
maybe that's what indian people think is
weird about white people and we're
getting ass surgeries
no everyone's doing it now you think so
um it's not only like get a load of this
uh leah cambridge a 29 year old
beautician from leeds in england
is said to have died this week after she
underwent the increasingly popular
cosmetic surgery at a clinic
was it in turkey or somewhere yeah the
guy was apparently a world-renowned
surgeon
and what they do is soup
they take fat from like your other parts
in your body yeah and they inject it
into your ass
but the catch is that it's actually
extremely dangerous because what
happened in this case
is that he injected the fat into one of
her main arteries that went through her
ass
and it went to her heart and her brain
and she had a [ __ ] stroke
yeah so how about that for ridiculous on
you know i mean like i don't know
i feel like we should be talking about
this mental illness that's in our
society
people are putting fat in their ass
um crazy [ __ ] dude yeah even cardi b has
a story about how she did
and like a surgery at an illegal place
just in some ladies basement i mean
that's probably people can't afford to
go to
probably the legitimate places
the procedure cost um
oh she she definitely went cheap
the procedure cost 6 500 pounds to 10
000 pounds in the uk but in the turkey
it costs three thousand pounds well i
don't know it's probably expensive in
turkey
but like man god that's so tragic like
jesus christ
i think we need to be talking about that
i think guys should talk more to their
girlfriends and tell them they really
don't need to do it well because i feel
like
it becomes like a competition between
women
and they start to feel insecure next to
that the article said the guy told her
she didn't hit it like what
what could he do yeah i don't know
i don't know it's so bad i i think that
but it's like you open instagram
and all you see is like this crazy
buddies like
unrealist actually unrealistic bodies we
used to consider unrealistic bodies in
this dialogue of like
super fit hard-working people that
achieved a god-like body yeah
now we're talking about people that are
injecting fat in their ass and then
little girls are being like how do i get
that ass
no i'm gonna go get fat injected in my
heart and have a stroke
whoop yeah it's really easy to it's
really easy to feel insecure when you
see all those
asses dude instagram is very
dangerous i'm i'm very i'm skinny and
like
pretty flat all around and it's like
when you look at those
all the instagram models these days it's
crazy
it's like do you feel bad when you see
that stuff
i'm pretty at peace with my body so i
don't
but i can see i can there was a point in
your life when you were
yeah there was when i was younger
but i think i mean i've i've talked to
our friends that's perfect just the way
you are
but i know and your friends not like too
flat
your ass is great everything's going on
there
it's a very regular to a skinny person
that's a great one one of the best
but like yeah i've talked to other
friends and i know
people feel pretty insecure and a lot of
people are doing these surgeries
a lot let's talk about not reach people
too good mythical morning let's talk
about that
yeah i don't know this whole thing about
like i
i feel like and it's the same in israel
so that's why i'm saying it's not
i don't think it's only here
so that was a whole discussion about
body issues so i hope that there was
something there interesting for you
and if you're considering um injecting
fat into your ass don't do it please
i frankly i on my part when i see kim
kardashian's ass
i'm like you have a disease
it looks like you have a tumor in your
ass
it just becomes like a almost like a
caricature
it looks um it looks like i mean to me
it looks really bad
how does she when she shits it must be
like a long way to the toilet
there's like a lot of space between the
ashes because it's so big
she must have to like either she spreads
open the ass cheeks super wide
or she's getting [ __ ] streaks on the
inside of her cheeks
and did not think about that think about
it
also these days you have to have like a
10 inch dick just to get inside of her
wouldn't you have to discuss with her
her wiping
you've got kim kardashian on the line
yeah
i'm not sure that's a conversation she's
a she's ready to have her no
she would not but seriously like how do
you even have sex with a girl that fat
like the barrier for entry is like eight
plus i don't think it works like that i
think the fat goes like sideways more it
just falls to the side i mean that
doesn't sound sexy to me ladies
keep your ass natural keep it all
natural
okay you're looking good you're
beautiful
and i guarantee you there's men
everywhere everywhere every corner you
turn that wants to [ __ ] you
just the way you are and most of them
don't even have a dick big enough to
penetrate
the ass on kim kardashian right eel
okay all right what else we got
well pep talk louis ck's back
i feel like i don't want to talk about
this not because i i'll talk about it
briefly i just
it's almost there's so much here louis
ck's back
um he just popped in apparently
you know it's funny because we were
talking with bert like yeah before this
happened
and we were like um louie is gonna be
back
and his opening line is gonna be like
some genius line
yeah and everyone's gonna be like oh
he's a genius and he's back
and we said like we don't know how long
it's gonna take
like maybe two years and all that
couple years and then the next day
you know what i gotta say a lot of
people were upset that he had the balls
to come back and that he hadn't been
punished
and that you know [ __ ] louis ck
that's not my angle i think he came
back too soon what i what i'm
disappointed in as him as a comedian
you can't just come back on stage and do
material like uh
nothing happened he didn't even address
it like
i did hear the material was funny well
yeah
i'm sure he's very funny yeah but it's
like
dude you had the mo the moment had to be
perfect
yeah he had to come out after a couple
years when people almost forgot him
and be like so how about them dodgers
huh or whatever i don't know
so it was way too soon just
people need enough time to like yeah it
was too soon
they're just the news but then someone
had a good point was it i don't remember
who brought it up was it dan
uh can someone take shredder out
he's dead shredder it's shredder's
birthday oh he's such a cutie pie i'm
gonna
cook him a filet mignon we said it was
shredder's birthday at the top right
yeah we're gonna cook him a filet mignon
tonight
i'm most excited for me to eat a
flamingo
um
i just think oh i forget who
said this but they're like he's probably
so depressed
and borderline even suicidal i don't
know if that's true or not but
like yeah that that was me saying that
and yeah you know
it makes me wonder a lot of these
comedians that you guys have even talked
to on the show
just talk about how like therapeutic
even for you ethan you know when you
come and do the podcast and everything
and you know louie his life is stand up
so
yeah it makes me wonder it's like i i
agree that i think it's way too soon for
him to come back but i almost wonder if
he was just sitting
at home alone and like i gotta get out
there and do this or i don't know what
i'm gonna do
you know yeah
i don't know his situation is a tough
one it's just mostly weird to just
not even acknowledge it yeah that's what
i mean that's when i'm disappointed
because
i don't know there was so much pressure
on that opening line of like oh [ __ ]
louie's back
i feel like he should have waited until
everyone almost forgot even that me too
was a thing like it was settled
you're like okay you too you too
and then wait another year
and then louie his opening line would be
something like
anyone want to see my deck right
close the doors anyone in here want to
see me masturbate
right you own it
too soon louie
that would have been a great opening
line would it not he just got out there
and just whipped it out
yeah don't even he goes like this lock
the doors
and then he takes his dick out
that would have killed so anyway that's
my two cents on that
guys this is the correct opinion zone
you watch these tuesday episodes for my
opinion which are correct and relevant
every time
if you disagree keep watching i don't
want to lose you as a viewer but just
know that you are wrong
um
the celeb hacker who hacked uh
jennifer lawrence and all the
celebrities who got all their nudies
leaked out into the world
the fappening as it were has pleaded
guilty
admitting that and here's what shocked
me about this story
he sent emails to the victims while
posing as members of online's
apple's online security personnel in
order to obtain their username and
passwords
this this amazing hacker that got all
these nudes
he was just doing a phishing scam that's
all it takes
i thought this was some like slick
underground crazy hacker
yeah he's just a guy who sent the email
to jennifer lawrence and said
hey please log into your apple account
i almost feel like that is what hacking
is like
90 of the time yeah like how often did
they actually have your password
well i thought it was some crazy thing
because he he had like dozens of
of celebrity nudes and
you know it was just a freaking fishing
scam so there you go get inspired you
guys
i think this is an inspiring twist on
this story to everyone out there who's
like
i want to see jennifer lawrence nude but
i mean i'm not you know i'm saying like
i'm not saying that specifically but
like
anything is possible sometimes
you will go to jail yeah you will go to
jail obviously there's consequences but
that's not the more the moral of the
story is not to steal people's nudes but
that
anything is possible did you think that
you could see jennifer lawrence nude by
simply
sending her a login credentials and
saying hey i'm from apple can you log in
now i'm not saying to do that but i'm
just saying get inspired
because this guy had a simple idea that
he took all the way to prison
and i'm saying it is inspiring in a
weird twist away he should never done
that
shame on him you know privacy matters
uh they should have never come out and i
should have never looked at them
but that being said get inspired
i think if you're looking to get
inspired you should subscribe to
t-series
is plugging they need all the help they
can get folks
[Applause]
not enough subscribers no i feel awful
for those slip that that was a huge
violin i want to
make clear that i was a huge violation
and
and uh a real a real
wacky shame you know but damn there's
something inspiring there though you
have to admit
nope just a little piece of [ __ ]
that is going through no reason you know
what he did it's like that movie um
the pursuit of happiness with will smith
where he had like the rubik's cube and
that got him the job
it's like the simple plan gets you all
the way
and that's what's inspiring
anyone anyone follow along okay let's
move on
thank you i'm waiting for that uh up
next
god this is going on and on we have a
lot more here getting kind of exhausted
i wonder if we should move some of this
over
we can skip we've got ariana groped
we've got
uh michael cohen
starts to go [ __ ] me and that we're
gonna go to that one
love that story well the ariana gropes
is pretty amazing too
all right let's just finish it up ariana
groped
so oh man ariana grande
is at the funeral of aretha franklin
and this slimy
slimy dude
gropes her live during a funeral
it's crazy [ __ ] ever it reminds me of
this clip we watched of
lou walsh grabbing that girl's ass it's
like they have a secret society where
they're like
i'm gonna they're like hey they like
push the boundary with each other
you know what i mean i'm gonna grope a
famous person and what are they going to
say
it's not even about the faintest person
they would do that to anyone
because it's yeah but it's just a sick
mind it's like they're daring each other
to get away with the craziest
stunt oh yeah but i'm sure he didn't
yeah i don't look at it like that i just
think
it's it's just like what is going on in
your head
so here it is anyway apologize
because i have to brush up my 20 years
old telling her
when i saw ariana grande on the program
i thought that was a new something at
taco bell
so meanwhile saying that he thought she
was a taco bell item aka
a snack and
the motion he's doing with his hand is
something so unnatural
did y'all enjoy this icon she's a
nightclub here
yeah he's like digging in here i've got
a gift so you can look it more closely
but
i like how he's saying on one hand i
girl i gotta give you all your respect
now give me that titty look at this
look how he's like gra he's like
really grabbing
i mean that's intentional as it gets
right i mean there's no way to explain
it in
any other way right no just because it's
like it's like
this and he's like digging in you know
yeah that's so creepy
you guys say these men of god lately are
not winning uh
the hearts and minds are not winning my
heart and mind
i guess that's all there is to that one
yeah he apologized whatever
um how can you just get away with an
apology though like doesn't the church
just like want to get rid of that guy
immediately well
i don't understand this apology was
really half-assed too maybe you can find
it i thought i had it here can you guys
find it
sure he's just like you know uh
i guess maybe i pushed it i was hugging
everyone
anyway i apologize it was basically just
that
said uh it would never be my intention
to touch any woman's breast
i don't know i guess i put my arm around
her maybe i crossed the border
maybe i was too friendly or familiar but
again i apologize
here we got a video of it
bishop ellis by the way let's just say
his name for the record
because i have to brush up my
28 year old daughter tells me dad you
are old at 60.
you may want to skip this
girl let me give you all your respect
i certainly want to apologize to ariana
and to her fans and to her family
and to her entire community if uh what i
said was taken
uh the wrong way and uh listen oh he's
talking about the taco bell comment
yeah he's about to the tick roping yet
yeah he's got a lot to answer for
uh maybe it's just a joke that went bad
but when you're doing the program
for nine hours you know you're trying to
keep it lively you try to
make some funny references and what have
you i love
everybody everybody that knows bishop
ellison greater grace knows that we love
everybody and listen it's not about
whether i
meant it or didn't mean it or whether
somebody took it the wrong way
i'm the one that said it and if it was
taken to be an offensive
statement i apologize that's the easiest
thing for me to do the right thing for
me to do
and i certainly hope that she will
forgive me and the last thing i want to
do is to be a distraction didn't address
the tech crap
this is all about her it's not about me
and i'm so sorry
if i inserted myself in a way that took
away from this very very very
frankly so i apologize to ariana and to
her community he never addressed the
tick grab
he addressed the taco bell grande uh
comment
i thought this is the video well the
thing is i've only seen it in
like a clip of it that i thought was in
reference but i watched the whole thing
he didn't even address
the freaking tit dig the thing is when
you grab a lady here
i don't know if she was wearing a wire
bra but first of all there's a wire
that's so obvious
but even if not like this motion here
is really i don't know who does that
look are you getting sexual
gratification from that
are you trying to massage her tit and
turn her on i mean what are you trying
to do
or is it just a weird creepy old world
power play of being like
i can do this and get away with it you
know it's the weirdest [ __ ]
hopefully this guy's gone man i'm sick
of these [ __ ]
holy men like
anyway anything else to add to that yolo
no
that's dude to get like groped like that
on live tv
during a funeral like she can't say
anything she was recoiling from it
yeah it's one of those situations you
can't really say anything
it's just really because it's not that
bad
it's just like right on the line just in
that crib zone
yeah it's like why you gotta be such a
creep yeah
and finally a tragic story to end the
episode
uh poor michael cohen uh
you know the sad unfortunate michael
cohen
trump's attorney that has flipped on him
and to work with the fbi
um has started a gofundme
to help um pay his legal fees
and i am we're just all so very
heartbroken over this dan can you
cue the music please um to help set the
mood
um
crickets do we have crickets dad
well apparently yeah nobody dan's off
mike shredder pooped
he pooped in the office yeah it's your
birthday
that's the only reason we're uh we're
letting them get away with it right now
a nice white one too
hopefully our office manager doesn't see
this
um what happened so
so i apologize are we talking about
michael cohen yeah we're a boy yeah
we're talking about
our boy um
huh um
yeah we wanted some sad music yeah i'm
sorry shredder i feel bad for porsche
fredrick
all right michael cohen truth fund
[Music]
on july 2nd 2018 michael cohen declared
his independence
from donald trump and his commitment to
tell the truth
and not because he was strong armed by
the fbi
to avoid criminal charges against
himself
michael cohen made the decision to take
a legal responsibility and continue his
commitment
to tell the truth michael decided to put
his family and his country
first now michael needs your financial
help michael cohen yes who in 2015
reportedly purchased
a 58 million dollar apartment building
in new york's upper east side needs your
help
desperately head on over to gofundme.com
h-q-j-u-p-j slash michael
cohen slash truth slash fun yes the same
michael cohen that
had a salary from donald trump of one
million dollars a year
is in desperate desperate need of your
help to fight
the truth now that he
is on the line for crimes against the
fbi
yes michael cohen the sad unfortunate
truth teller
that we all support him in his hour of
need
and we threw up that url on the lower
third yes you guys please head on over
go fund me yes the same michael cohen
who at one point
was worth over a hundred million dollars
thanks to his ownership stake in more
than 200 new york city taxi medallions
my heart breaks for this sad courageous
brave man who has put the truth telling
first when he was faced with prison time
from the fbi
yes he's a brave daring man he needs all
the help we can get
so please head on over to michael
cohen's gofundme
at q at gofundme.com
h-q-j-u-p-j michael-cohen-truth
look at that face he needs all the help
he can get folks
this honorable man with a net worth of
100 million dollars
he's at 170 000 after out of half a
million guys we need to pay
his legal fees now
because if we don't then the fbi is
going to lock him up for crimes he
committed
[Music]
and he won't be able to uh
you won't be able to trail the truth any
longer folks
[Music]
and with that i say we're pretty much
done
so guys you can keep it going i was
enjoying that
oh no it started over so guys in the
spirit of michael cohen
the spirit of telling truth and
spreading justice in this planet and
this earth
[Music]
you know and i know you're not worth a
hundred mil you don't make a million
dollars a year
like michael cohen but you can spare a
buck
[Music]
and so remember to join us a week from
today bill
burr is going to be our guest the great
the wonderful the funny
there will be no episode no episode
thursday
yes we are going to canada we are taking
a moment our mobile game is coming out
this thursday stay tuned for that
but enough about us i'm going to be
talking about bill burr about
hopefully setting up a truth fund for
michael cohen
bill burr flies helicopters he can
afford to give this guy 10 bucks
i actually should ask bilberry about
this i'm curious what's this take
so thank you all for tuning in i hope
you have a terrific wonder wonderful
week ahead shredder is [ __ ] on the floor
i need to address that
just clean up properly thank you dan for
handling that
congratulations to uh joe on the shoe
nice
and to all you at home who really
got educated today and this h3
correct opinion zone ela do you have
anything to add
oh no are you feeling sad for michael
cohen
i'm really stunned do you have money to
donate to michael cohen
no really
not even a dollar a dollar can save this
child's life
cold-blooded well i hope you all are
more generous than you will
thank you guys and we will see you
next time thank you to michael cohen for
sponsoring this episode
thanks for watching thanks for watching
you